I have amazing video of new Republican
strategist the new campaign manager one
of the new campaign managers for Donald
Trump Kellyanne Conway before she was
working for Trump she demanded that we
see Donald Trump's tax returns so she
goes on TV and she is asked hey you
called for the release of Donald Trump's
tax returns when you weren't running his
campaign certainly you're standing by
that right Kellyanne Conway
no she's not take a look at the video
let's talk about Donald Trump's tax
returns back in April you said on CNN
that you want Trump to be transparent
right listen about this alliance between
you first
Kellyanne between John Kasich and Ted
Cruz this alliance shall we say that
Donald Trump is calling collusion is
this fair game are they playing by the
rules here absolutely it's completely
transparent Donald Trump's tax returns
aren't I'd like to see those be
transparent okay now you're in charge of
Donald Trump's campaign given that and
given how you feel or we gonna see
Donald Trump's tax return soon
so now that I'm on the inside I know
something I didn't know them which is
he's under audit and what mmm-hmm and he
has said very clearly and I back him up
completely yeah that when the audit is
completed he will release the tax
returns and let me just say something
about transparency it comes in many
different forms data as does
accountability yeah because truthfulness
and we can't imagine going up against a
less transparent less accountable more
sort of rigged and corrupt individual as
our political opponents in Hillary
Clinton she's had a terrible week when
it comes to being transparent and
accountable whether it's the revelations
of the pay-for-play
at the in the State Department they I
know that you CNN is very much on top of
and your reporting is data as well as as
well as the what happened at the Clinton
Foundation anyway and we are and we are
talking about that for sure but in this
particular interview and these questions
are about Donald Trump and and you
mentioned the audit according to his
lawyers the years 2002 to 2008 are no
longer under audit so would you release
those tax returns No
now I would this entire tax return
debate is somewhat confounding to me in
the following sense yeah she just
doesn't get why people want this well
the reason people want the tax returns
is the same reason you wanted them a
couple months ago right I mean we there
could be so much in there being under
audit doesn't prevent you from releasing
your tax returns but more importantly
everybody knew Trump was saying he was
under audit and that's why he wasn't
releasing them how did it take her
becoming part of his campaign to learn
that he's been saying that for years and
let me also add it usually takes a
little while for the IRS to audit you
the odds that Trump's 2015 tax returns
are under audit are almost implement all
most non-existent probability I almost
feel bad for her right she was caught
earlier saying that on video yeah and
someone like her doing so many
appearances it's hard to keep track of
what you say sure I get it and it's it's
hilarious
basically what Kellyanne is saying is
I'm on Trump's payroll now you don't
want me getting fired
do you or maybe what she means is and
this is I think actually even more
likely now that I'm on the inside and
I've talked to people on the campaign I
know why Trump absolutely cannot release
those tax returns because they would be
so devastating compared to just
continuing to not release them and
that's really what I think is going on
here send me your thoughts on this we
will take a break and be back with more
right after this